you know that makes it sound like his
torture his whole journey but he can't
help but
having been a witness to it um you know
just as friends for
for that long uh i have never seen an
entrepreneur suffer more than him
and uh you know he's been public about
that like you do not want to be me
um he has suffered to for those
companies he has suffered to get them
where they are
it has not been easy can you analyze
elon
in that aspect like is there is it just
he can't help but
he must see the change that he uh hopes
for in the world
he's just incredibly hard working and uh
he's very talented as well
uh and i don't think people understand
that he actually is a really brilliant
engineer
at the end of the day he actually knows
what he's doing um and he asked the
right questions i mean
people were kind of aghast that he was
asking vlad such good questions and
they're like
oh my god elon's the best journalist on
the planet and it was like
that's what happened anybody who knows
elon knows he asks great questions i
mean i've been i used to
have dinner in l.a and my book agent
also was sam harris's agent and sam and
i met um
through john brockman and we became
friends because we lived near each other
and i was friends with elon
and then i used to invite them to both
dinner and brentwood because one lived
in bel air one lived in santa monica and
i lived in brentwood
and we would go to this place papone
this italian restaurant and every
tuesday
for years we would just the three of us
every other tuesday or so we'd have
dinner
and uh i'd sit there and sam wanted to
know about ai and elon's talking about
artificial intelligence because he's on
the board of deep mind and
uh elon wanted to know about atheism and
meditation and
all this other stuff that uh you know
sam was an expert on i got to sit there
and like
just listen to these two guys talking
and they have both
piercing intelligences but elon he goes
straight
to the to the gut like the the questions
that no engineer wants to hear
is like just the basic stuff that yeah
it's like why the hell are you doing it
this way
yeah when the obvious solution is like
much easier or
or this or that like why haven't you
tried this you can figure things out i
mean he's a problem solver
you